the computational foundations of or the
computational version of the evolution
story which is perhaps a somewhat new
interdisciplinary field relative to what
we've been hearing about the past two
days and we're very fortunate to have in
this room some of the kind of
foundational influence influential
thinkers of this new area so the story
is new and they might even be hope that
in four months time if this with the
work of everyone here we might have
sniffily more say about story but to get
started I'm very happy to be introducing
sisters Papa me to you so he's worked on
a huge fraction of areas of things in
Geoscience so from computational
complexity theory graph theory game
theory economics from computational
perspective optimization also databases
AI learning theory geometric algorithms
many many other topics some of you may
also not be where he's also a prolific
writer of novels including a graphic
novel that I think made it as high as
number six on the Amazon bestseller list
for four minutes highest for so yeah
that further do these are a few happy
moments until the Sun up Islands
many thanks for thanks all for coming
I don't know how many of you have you
know I don't like this metaphor how many
of you have been in a real boot camp so
it's not a nice place right yeah you
know but that's that's why I saw you
know but I I hope you're likely have no
evening never could come there is one
drill sergeant who wants to give
everybody an easier time okay you know I
my mission is to be all right
so computation of this revolution what
to health can this be okay and what I'll
start by pointing out that it's nothing
new you know 200 years ago this is
charge Babbage the other great british
follow the 19th century ok knows who is
the great grandfather of the computer ok
so he wrote a treatise that 9th
bridgewater treatise it's around I
believe it 1813 verlo bridge water
cannon down a series of books sort of
pointing to the goodness to the to the
to the benevolence of the Supreme Being
and here is charged Babbage's
contribution he actually did did say
something like that ok so you know not
know you know he didn't use the word
algorithm but but but he did say to be
his argument is that evolution happens
but it's algorithmic occasion so that
and nice try I think
second so these are these are the famous
debate you know debate in absentia I
guess between between Wallace and Darwin
where it as in cars as you know Wallace
great feel natural scientist of the 19th
century while he was away in Malaysia
burning with fever
he sort of he considered natural
selection and he wrote this letter to
the other great naturalist who he
admired and Darwin read it acted with
impeccable academic integrity he
convened a sort of a debate where both
his and Wallace's papers were you know
drafts were read and if you read these
which I I hope you'll do whether they're
amazing documents and the good part of
the argument of both Swamy or they have
a lot of things in common one of these
is that they they point out that
Exponential's are incompatible with life
okay so and that the argument is
Exponential's is what is what is what
population growth predicts how come we
don't see them and the answer is that
life is hard and only the fit survive
okay so and that's the beginning of the
argument and of course we have the
original species were you know were at
Berkeley the Department of rhetoric used
to teach a course based on this because
it is
in some sense the world history's most
prominent example of scientific return
incidentally in in the web you can find
our genetic tree over of the of these
six editions okay you know with a lot of
commentary including an interesting
aspect is the number of references of
the world God which has an interesting
of harmonical to a great thinker of
evolution are Bustos vitamin but the
other vitamin okay you wrote a great a
great in his inaugural address as the
president of ribose as the electron of
ribose universe they believed he wrote
several papers one of them was a polemic
against Lamarck in which he used really
modern you know what what what would be
200 years later modern cryptography his
argument as explained actually by David
Haig in a recent article essentially is
that the mapping from genotype to
phenotype that but the germ cells
separate from the soma early and as a
result the the mapping from genotype to
phenotype is sort of one way in other
words it's difficult to be in that okay
so so life experience cannot be we
cannot be inflicted upon the germ cells
of course yes sorry I know but but but
but but one of the things that one of
the themes of my hope of this talk is
that dimension of space and magnitude is
not does not always tell the whole story
okay that there is something there is
something about some functions
from a very small space you know to a
large so we know from from before
between special different dimensions but
still very bad you know that a
computationally intractable okay so okay
yeah good point and of course what what
we know soon after that we about the
people you know we you know evolution
came much closer to bother little
science because this great man notices
that inheritance is discrete and this is
deadly I don't know how many of you know
but but I believe that the number of
citations with the first 35 years of
this book you know arguably one of the
ten greatest works of science in science
was not very much and I have not read
these papers but those who have tell me
that these people didn't get it okay
but of course the beginning of the night
of the that essentially things changed
and there was the crisis in evolution
the sort of Thomas Kuhns scientific
crisis heat evolution and these were
these great mathematicians or sort of
you know if if you are a mathematician
and many of us are so you know we should
be proud of this is this is an amazing
feat of mathematics or you know that but
it's so creative the modern the modern
approachable is no Darwinism and at
about the same time something else was
happening okay so no some other great
mathematicians were founding were sort
of researching the computers okay so we
know and the theory
so computer science was sort of unique
among scientists in that so basically
this is a talk also talking about
computer science okay so you know it's
it's it's in some sense it's you know
it's not easy task it's talking about
one's mother okay you know so so you so
it will it will be hard load with not to
have you know I'll try not to make it an
empty place right no but but but but
computer science is unique among
Sciences because of two things okay
first of all its theory came first okay
and it's it's it's it's incarnation was
the result of theory okay so these the
greatest mathematical mind of that era
this man was the man who actually
brought you know God completed to
existence the second the second
uniqueness unique and interesting thing
about computer science is that computer
science was born with a very painful
understanding of its own limitations
okay because the first paper in computer
science is by this man and basically it
shows that there are uncomputable
problems okay so so so that you know
other sciences okay so they realize
their limitations like the rest of us
the midrange okay so but but but not not
computer science okay
so these as I said is is meeting of
minds between many communities but most
notably evolutionary biologists and
computer scientists okay so and this is
a talk about this curve this meeting of
minds and why right sort of it's clear
what you guys bring to the table okay so
I know the world's most fascinating
problem and deep thought by brilliant
people over 150 years okay so so let me
try to tell you what we bring to the
table right it's it's a really know the
here of computing which is this is dudes
type of acacia good for the few meetings
I'm assisting with the mathematical
framework stance and methodology for
understanding kappa d kappa capabilities
and limitations a computer so this
sounds like a limited project ok but
it's extremely open-ended ok and for
example why is the Census Bureau
computing organizing semesters like
evolutionary biology computing ok and
the reason is this ok so don't know that
but that what we call this is part of
the of ideology DNA obesity okay so we
know pit the length of computation and
our motto is that what the point of view
the fear of computing is applied to a
field of science often not always not
without bounds progress happens ok and
there are many examples of that and all
of them will be eventually celebrated
you know for example quantum mechanics
and
and and and he is actually our sister
our sister program but also statistical
physics game theory in economics social
science and I'm making up and of course
molecular biology and also evolution
okay incidentally of all these fields I
believe that the special affinity
between computational biology and here
is my lame attempt at explaining
everything that in biology there is
something that can be called innate
explicit college okay by this ending the
following that physics has lost but
there are laconic and they don't they're
not reminiscent of a computer program
okay and and in other words there is no
there are no particles in the solar
system that tell us whether Newton's
laws are cubic or quadratic okay but but
whereas in in biology in life we have
okay you know so this is an intuitive
reason why I believe that biology and
also social science is is a more apt
fear of computation in anyway so let me
give you the theory of cognitive
computing in a nutshell alright I mean
oh what is this is trouble so basically
it's about you know it's also a life
science okay so we believe that life is
hard and occasionally computers can help
and that's what we call algorithms and
often times they can't and that's what
we've all complexity okay so algorithm
complexity
people and people will tell me the fear
of computing is not just about our
groups a complex need arise but let's
let's talk about all this and complexity
because they are the backbone of the of
the of the of the modern theory of
computing so what the basic specimen
over the fear of computing is what we
call a computational problem which is
something that computers much solved
okay so no it's one money one tiny
manifestation that slightest help which
might be solved by a computer and what
is a computational problem for the time
being but we're going to modify that
Sigma Z that it's an infinity of inputs
and each one with them is looking for an
outlet okay
and the output of course must be in a
particular relationship with them and
this relationship is always very well
understood okay at least we know how to
solve a problem but we know what you
want
okay the otherwise sort of there's very
little theory that can be done the
inputs and outputs can be represented as
fillings or bits okay that's that's some
kind of occupational protein your
preoccupation that that that you can do
come back them to bits and if you have
graphs mattresses anything sort of know
tape you can do that so so an algorithm
and you know what an algorithm is sort
of you know way you know it you know you
you have been to very mental school you
learn long division so you know it's
basically a process that is well
understood and so on I mean oh so I have
expressed usually in a particular
rigorous language but nobody's made for
a computational problem see first of all
you must be correct which means that we
must eventually stop with the right
output for me to put for eg policy so if
you give it an input of C it will stop
will eventually the right output and
then there is this interesting function
piece of a C of n which is the number of
elementary steps what's an elementary
step excellent question never leaves the
good discussion okay so you know
anything anything is you know what you
think as an elementary step is probably
good
the matter is that for him a number of
elementary steps the algorithm takes
until completion when supplied with an
input of length n okay that's what is
this this variable says is the length of
the input and this should be maximized
over rollin boots of like that okay so
what we are doing is that is called
worst-case analysis okay and this is
sort of you know the pride and burden
overfilled all right let me know that
that we that we that we we emphasize for
reasons that are both cultural and and
very scientific okay so we know in other
words they're both defensible and and
and personal oratorio and and cultural
what I so it was okay why why why okay
all right so very quickly right I'm you
know so solar you know this is this is a
so why why don't we do for example
average case analysis right many reasons
okay the basic reason is that to do an
average case analysis you need an input
distribution
equal distributions are you know
otherwise you won't have a Bayesian
private for the input all right
which is fine okay and so when we know a
prior we always worried we all know
there are men computer scientists work
on twin average-case complexity way but
this is a second-class citizen solve you
know in our work and the reason is the
color that that imagine that you that
you have an algorithm for finding
shortest paths all right and know
between in a graph what is the able to
put your input graphs right what are
your input graphs I mean you can imagine
a few a few a few plausible models sort
of distributions of little graphs but
then you realize the following that this
program will not run in isolation will
not wait for organic inputs to give
output but will be a subroutine in a
bigger program that does something else
okay
so the input is the output of the other
program alright so it's much less
plausible to assume that there is an
organic distribution of describes what
this stupid program spits out okay so so
that in order you know that the
hierarchy and sort of you know and
recursion and so on up of computer
science or you know makes it implausible
so we know that but you know that it's
much more much much more interesting so
you know much much more productive to
think about about all right yes yes I'm
talking about the primes so let me let
me let me stay what let me stay the way
you start that this is an excellent
point
all right so I want to give you a few
computational problems of you may have
heard of linear programming basic
dimension before famous travel itself no
problem I know you have heard about it
integer programming the able to in oval
in your programming and I'll tell you a
few a few problems that come from the
study of life secrets and linemen and
sequences Android okay so it's sequence
alignment to the input is two sequences
in the parameter B and the output sort
is an alignment to that most big skips
ANOVA right and as you all know there is
an algorithm a with T of s AB AC and AC
is not this a since the rotation from a
previous
okay such that is over the Roman square
okay so it can't be done in n square and
when these small when other words you
know that the things are can be aligned
this can be solved the linear time and
the rest is history okay no you know
this there are amazingly popular codes
that actually do things okay and much of
molecular computational biology is based
on it
so that's sequence alignment one of the
successes so to speak of algorithms
sequence centroid is a problem I made up
but but I know you know people have
things like these have have have have
made researchers lose sleep now so you
are given s sequences several sequences
and the parameter V again and you want a
new sequence which has a business at
most D from each of these input
sequences right and it turns out that
this time all algorithms that one can
think of other exponential right and as
you all know okay exponential sorry
compatible life okay so we don't like
all right so and here the T is the total
total length of a sex okay yeah thanks
we want to find out that okay in which
case you type a bigger deal okay
so on I'm doing a note by presenting
problems in a very stylized way so that
sort of you know so that they stay clear
so here is what here is sort of you know
in some sense the the centroid of our
own field all right amino NP is the
class of all search problems or I call
problems like the ones I've shown you
peez all such problems that can be
solved in polynomial time okay for
example secrecy on a sequence online
we strongly believe that p is not equal
20 and we have not you know after 50
years we still have across the proof
this has joined the real motive of the
deepest problems in mathematics it's
probably the deepest problem and so
forth i conjecture set my second humble
conjecture is that such sequence Android
is not in P okay cannot be solved in
polynomial time and the fact is that
these two conjectures are equivalent
right because it turns out that sequence
Android is condenses the power of all
empty you can any search problem you can
through a very complicated algorithm you
can reduce it to sequence Android so
sequence that road is empty complete
okay that's that's that's that's how
that's the technical term for such
problems and therefore if P is not equal
to P as you all believed sequence
Android is incompatible with life okay
so I know it's it's it's its explanation
so what's the theory for it
it's a comprehensive methodology for the
onion communication on top you develop a
very efficient algorithms for them if
you try like a good soldier many times
and you when you don't when you
establish complex the lower bounds such
as that the completeness and how do you
resolve to more complex strategies such
as approximations and heuristics which
I'm going to come back again all right
so I want to give you so this is you
know I've showed you a couple of
problems like sequence alignments but a
keen to the two verse to the to the
study of light oops I'm going to just
just shoot five minutes by show you a
story all right I'm nowhere where it is
a new career algorithm some better than
life okay which is sort of much more
interesting and you'll know
the protein folding problem right and no
that's it immensely hard problem sort of
in in in some sense in theoretical
physics you want to find the the best
the best they have lowest energy
configuration of over over all the
string of amino acids over sequence of
amino acids and then there is something
called at least would be called I don't
know if you have heard this this this
phrase now if you have hear the phrase
now but 20 years ago you good you did
let me toss paradox which is this how
come this cubed molecule solves in in a
millisecond what the biggest computers
in the world cannot solve ok you know
this this this this is an interesting
interesting sort of you know somewhat
somewhat facetious but no it does the
way of putting this this this of
extracting we wish the paradox a
conundrum out of this situation right so
the paradox depends so to speak but this
problem is relevant for evolution know
know so you know so so so right these
are all wonderful questions I get it or
you know what so you know we I I have I
have I have an opinion the matter we
also it will probably come out in the
next time in the are crystals was they
serve a paradox right I mean if I want a
say for example find the the maximum of
a you know bunch of integers right you
know I just make strains of spaghetti
that length and then sort of stand the
money working along this strand out
right you know that is sort of like that
kind of physical algorithm
you know I've solved the problem much
faster than you know sort of theorems
about ok ok so so so you so you so so
you you know you probably don't count
the time it took me to cut the spaghetti
yes I mean or so so so that you know the
point is that that there are some
scientific reasons to believe okay
that's that's it that's that's something
else
I'm delighted delighted see that point
of yourself but you know what is what is
our sister program studying okay you
know our sister program is studying Toto
quantum quantum computation I mean oh
what what does it come from okay it
comes from from fineman's ingenious
observation all right you know that that
computers can simulate all classical
systems all right
including stacks of spaghetti all right
so whatever you can achieve with your
spaghetti algorithm I can't with my
computer with my digital computer okay
the only exception that a final was able
to find was condom systems all right and
hence for thirty years later we were
starting quality okay so that's in other
words that's why nobody's posada
spaghetti compatible I don't because
because sort of you know we understand
that this under control
I don't know so okay point here which is
the the the evolution it doesn't care
about this problem the evolution has a
problem which it tries to solve
involving the proteins which is finding
proteins for business okay okay so so so
so you are you are with you are with you
you know you you can give the five more
next minutes of my talk I guess you just
need that okay so good good right yeah I
mean I agree with you so so here sorry
okay yeah I'll explain yeah so around
1990 biologists code can't deal then at
UCSF now at Stonybrook
came up with something called the HP
model so basically it says all right I
mean oh I know there are 20 amino acids
but let's say there are two amino acid
Hydra feel you can hydrophobic okay that
one knows it's alright and then
basically a protein is a string of
hydrophilic and hydrophobic way and now
how do you fold it first of all you fold
in two dimensions obviously okay because
we can and then you fold in two
dimensions so here is how you fold
basically you fold it you basically fold
it on degrees in such a way that as many
things as you can are next to each other
all right I mean oh so basically the
score is which means lower lower
you know how low is the energy of this
well it's 4 because 4 there are 4 4 4
incidental neighborhood neighboring
neighborhoods of hydrophilic hydrophobic
amino acids all right so that's
everybody understands the problem so
basically it says all right I mean no
one can be a cell or it cannot solve the
real problem let's let's at least at
least work on a cartoon problem right no
one and that's the cartoon problem all
right two dimensions to two amino acids
just a simple score and then about 10
years later a bunch of people including
our group proved that veg defaulting
provision to commit okay and in some
sense this is rabbit house followed of
sharpened explanations are incompatible
with life I mean exactly what Wallace
and argument which is basically that
that that you don't see explore
exponential to exponential growth in
life it's unsustainable okay so it's
does not scale which is what computer
scientists think ok even though this is
in some sense the cred of computer
science awesome ok
I mean we use and reduce the function X
okay I mean oh don't don't get me wrong
with that right I mean oh and and we
love it ok and it seems worse even
better
ok but but but when I say expand any no
I mean the exponential growth is
unsustainable it it doesn't it doesn't
scale it's not computations about
okay and so the question is can it be
that you know that that that these cubed
molecules solve any health problem what
is the real problem simpler than HP
cartoon which is hard to believe okay
because the real problem is of course
much more complicated and there is
another fault which is what panel
sketched well to the beaded proteins
have been selected actual proteins and
organisms have been selected solavei for
disease and the remember sort of anova
tender completeness is a corollary of
worst case Cimino because even the
hardest problems health is the inputs
okay there is no hardware problem that
the traveler says no problem all right
Graham and yet it does have it does have
simply booze okay I can solve this hat
Ravi sir you can solve this okay very
very good very good domain so so so so
what okay that's actually very good but
I have to this is something absolutely
not you have to talk about that the
Furio complex this asymptotic it's not
only worst case but it was asymptotic
okay
it means that when it's exponential it
could be 2 to the square root of N or to
the square root of n over 10 okay in
which case anyone 2200 is not a problem
right I mean oh yeah I totally agree
right okay so that you don't know yes I
know but it's it but it's definitely
something about to keep in mind yes
well let me yes I know No
so so so I think I think I think I think
I think I think I think Monty Monty
Daniel and I are not out of the same
page okay okay so all right so so what
I'm saying is that life is hard but
natural natural natural selection can
fail paper his inputs and a bunch of
years ago no we did experiment so I will
just wanna just wanted to give to tell
you about these experiments because it
also it also prepares you for something
that comes next which is heuristics we
did experiments with the Traveling
Salesman problem so here's what we did
we created the population of TSP in
Boots in other words we created a
population of maps right of city maps so
each individual in this population looks
like this right and then what we did is
is so we we evolved this these
populations through mutation but not a
combination this means the following but
we allowed some of these some of these
maps to change a little sort of you know
in other words we chose at random a few
cities and and move them a little around
okay
and the question is which maps did we
change and we and we favored maps that
were feet well fit means that a stupid
algorithm that the device did well okay
or if you wish just judges just just to
come to two Monty's point of view when I
said the stupid dog will did well it was
like like a simulated annealing I'd type
of algorithm and we said did well when
it did not find much diversity in
the in the in the output okay so maybe
maybe the landscape was had a deep well
somewhere but we don't care about that
okay right I mean also it exactly we
didn't solve the problem
we tied okay that's you know something
that that natural nature problem
possibly does and and after a few
generations the population all looks
like that so you know it was sort of
funny but but yes I mean oh it will get
a population of boring instance of the
traveler said about right away so these
taught us at least one thing in order to
have a visitor easy time publishing it I
mean nobody taught us one thing that you
can sort of you know evolved not good
solutions but at least good eases
cooking okay so know that no this is
something that yeah question
I understand I understand so so it's
it's hard because we're not nature you
know that that we don't do what nature
that okay which is which is obviously
some heuristic that has that has that
has creates good basis well computers
cannot do it
okay so so very likely this is generate
the discussion I'm you know I don't I
don't agree with Daniel or less than us
less the remark but I'll go on okay so
far I have told you that algorithms are
ways of mapping the inputs that you have
in your hand and if at any time you're
ready go up to that level alright so you
know but there are some very interesting
situations where the input is given to
you bit by bit and you must present you
must do something
what before the next bit is available to
you is this clear I mean oh so these are
called online algorithms and a lot of
computer science deals with online now
so what I'm saying they put output
paradigm is not Universal okay we do
start the other things and I'm going to
give you one my favorite are going to
know this and it's the memory problem it
is the for every day you must choose one
of an expert's all right let me know so
you have a set of an expert so you must
choose one to follow verifies imagine of
it as a financial advice and the advice
expert ion deity it results in again G
sub IT and it can be both negative and
positive right so you you are your solo
you are putting your hands in the your
faith in the hands of an expert and
so these things Jesus or Whitey's are
completely arbitrary I don't come from a
distributor you know they you can even
think that fate or your worst enemy or a
prankster is supplying them to be trying
to embarrass you okay
worst case again No
then the challenge is to do as well as
the best expert in retrospect okay so
basically you want to do something that
will that will that will do as well as
the best expert in the among the end in
the bunch would have done okay if you
wish you want to have forget this I mean
you want to have forget the experts you
want to create a portfolio and every day
change it in such a way that your
portfolio will perform as well as the
best talking about homophobia as if you
had in from the beginning chosen one
stroke instead the best [ __ ] psycho
okay that's one that's the challenge it
sort of seems impossible and yet it can
be achieved and it can be done this has
this is such an amazing fact that it has
been discovered forgotten and we
discovered many times in economics an
economist called Hammond discovered at
58 so economists call this Hammond
persistency thomas cover a brilliant
control theorist from from a stanford
who died recently came up with it in
which we study of financial financial
mathematics in 1991 when artificial
intelligence workers in computer science
discovered a corded we know discovered
by regression then other vision cultures
also researchers discovered it and coded
boosting people in game theory called no
regret learning and i guess what what
theoretical be the science is proud of
is that
very discovered a blast but it had
forgotten it
and actually it's telling other people
about it away that's what I'm doing now
all right so so and this algorithm is
called I can evaluate multiplicative
weights up there and initially assign
all experts the same weight or
probability right I'm not so you say all
right I mean argue I'm agnostic you guys
all have the same or in fact thing of
the situation of the expense as a stock
portfolio right amino dots and at each
step that's the whole algorithm increase
the weight of it by this particular
quantity okay which is multiplied by 1
plus Epsilon a small multiplier and the
smaller you keep it the more sort of
header here you are hedging your bets
times how well they did or badly they
did right ok so every that day so every
day you you change your portfolio in
some sense reflecting very faithfully
how how each stock did ok that's an
amazingly simple algorithm and the
theorem is that it does approximately as
well as the best that particular day
that particular day ok so basically you
react you react instinctively as you
would have sort of you know it's a very
much or algorithm or no it's not it's
not it's not very unlikely you know it's
not hard to believe that maybe even
organism good of you to do something
like that ok so so it does as well as
the best expert right
and ok proof incidentally ok when I when
I when I you know I have told you what
the theoretical the scientists do sort
of know in very sort of top-level
informal terms okay
I'll tell you a little more informally
first of all we project in black as you
know
but so that's one thing we do
differently and two we we we are inter
you know we laugh calculations but we
are very interested in improving in that
you know it is stealing our
understanding of a problem through an
intercept here okay so a lot of our
energy goes into proving theorems and we
use for that sometimes very
sophisticated mathematics usually
probability above in authority but also
other things like like you know another
an analysis geometry that's why sort of
you know the same assistive is or is
organizing semesters for geometry
analysis number theory and so so in
anyway so there is a proof that proves
that okay I'm going to give you only the
intuition of this book each day the
probability P I that I'm going to choose
this error expert next day becomes PR I
multiplied by this what did you wish are
you know sort of no because epsilon is
so small it's basically the exponent the
exponential over of this and after many
days P I is a is sort of proportional
minor we know modulo normalization to
the expectation of how well in other
words how well the stock so to speak has
performed so far okay as a result the
portfolio will consist almost exclusion
of the best performing stock okay
it is a clear now it's not exactly end
of the end of the proof okay because
maybe you are out of phase with the best
stock all right in other words you
natural date we know its growth by not
by not giving it enough weight so so so
maybe you didn't take advantage of this
girl but it turns out that simple
potential function argument proves that
this come up happen consistently
okay so then that's and that's what and
this is talk of you know the intuition
behind the proof which seems like you
had two experts never go like this so
then it's a much easier then it's a much
easier we know then it's a much easier
basically right I mean oh it's a you
know if you have even
many experts going like this then it's a
much easier problem okay so you know
there's a much easier way to see you
know what if you want to win over there
there is you know if you want to look at
you know very severe is a nice proof
Kostas shorted me two days ago but a
very bloom has every Blum has a husband
line so you know for for then if has a
simple proof this one in order to
complete this proof you want a potential
function argument which are always
magical and you don't know where they
came from
okay you know it's good now can he be
quite bad no no it's it's fine it's good
it's actually typing everyone no no
would you if they were each I mean this
is kind of a cartoon assist have special
case for like if you had them you know
every day like that exactly equal than
either expert okay okay okay here's my
answer I forgot to tell you that we're
talking the expectation okay for about
the decay they be gained from okay right
I'm you know so so so it's it's okay
okay Cimino so yeah we are we are we do
we love worst case by expectation of the
in other words wot wotty wot wot in the
end to have done in expectation as well
that's why physics is not is not
applicable everywhere okay so
yes so so so let me let me let me
convince you so K so we have built-in
concentration okay so today I referred
do happen but but but we're good okay so
that's that's that's the in fact the
same algorithms souls the most coveted
problems in our field okay it was really
nonlinear complex programming zero-sum
games network congestion so you know if
we can solve it by other means
well I'm exaggerating who can also solve
it by by multiplicative weight update
which is an amazing thing sort of you
know we still have to recover from the
shock so okay so right that function is
matters but I'd right right yes so so
you want you want you want to be on the
precise statement I love it okay so the
precise statement is the following that
if you choose your epsilon to be about 1
over square root of the top T so if you
do a year it's going to be 19 one of the
19 okay then you you what what your what
your what your what you expected what
your expected are we are expected
average is 1 over square root of T close
to the to the to the best expert
alright one thing that I want to that I
want to finish this this part of my talk
with is talk about heuristics inspired
by evolution right um you know this is
an amazing part so in a very very
generous part of the intellect we
interface between evolution and and
computer science and and of course I
have to talk about it
just just precaution is there is there
anybody here who works in this area is
there anybody out there or shall the
earth so so it's you know I'm this is
going to be broadcasted and archived so
I have to be a little the little
civilized here you know but but so there
has been immense inspiration okay as
soon as people realize that they cannot
that they cannot solve all problems they
they look to for inspiration to to do
evolution in fact so you know one of the
earliest papers is an amazing technology
for that very very proceeding particular
for IBM called designed by natural
selection so look there were two papers
of the radion local search which
basically is ladies selection by by by a
mutation and then of course think you
know physicists came in and and
appropriated the field okay you know the
calls it simulate a living organ you
know which which i think is the
secondary the secondary inspiration what
I'm saying is this okay sort of you know
threes became released this became so
popular that eclipses and I feel that
this is this is this is tough okay you
know because because all right no no I
realize that this is I realized I had I
realized accuracy of of the of the
metaphor okay no I'm just saying it's
not it's not the most upstanding it's
not it's not it's not it's not the
the only ones then there was there was
nice baby doubles and match came up with
something called goal the winners which
then tabu search was already in the in
the cards and all that amia so we have a
whole stable of very interesting
heuristics inspired by evolution sort of
you're with mutations any simulated
annealing of course acceptance or or or
or rejection of mutations with
probabilities or decreasing with
temperature and temperature indication
all right
and then on this corner you have genetic
algorithms ok so Jared come to rhythms
you know the others have seen so far
maintained just one one solution just a
few number few numbers of small
population solutions these are serious
about the population what they do is
then called the solutions as some kind
of genotype and the next generation is
created by mutations and usually by a
recombination and this was sort of you
know that the man who brought us all
this is Joe Holland in a very fragile
book in nineteen eighty okay where he
proposed the genetic algorithms as both
a very interesting way of studying
evolution and also as as a very
promising way for sorting optimization
problems and very you know there are so
many other things okay there is
something called evolutionary strategies
which is which is genetic algorithms on
who working on on vectors of real
numbers there's some Kalevala cell
programming which is the same thing
applied the problem of designing good
programs and genetic programming which
is another way of looking at where genes
are used actually differential evolution
and auto mentions other other wonderful
algorithms inspired by by our life like
ant colony avoidance behavior girls
little cuckoo algorithms
and of course you know something that
that is that is perhaps a bit more
interesting is is there is a very very
interesting strain of research on
artificial life-form programs that
actually and and and I know that our
Chairman here is a great aficionado of
this of this and worker in this in this
very interesting strain so ironically
it's a rough classification okay there
is something that call simulated
annealing which is variants of the local
search algorithm one solution or very
few solutions maintain a mutation by no
recombination and this corresponds
directly squarely to a sexual evolution
and genetic algorithm irrational
solutions maintain genetic coding new
generation produced for the mutation
cluster combination and this is
correspond to sexual revolution right
and a sexual dilution population yes yes
yes yes yes yes right yeah you know but
in some sense of sexual revolution on
population as you know it does matter
much so you know it's it's you know it's
it's independent experiments innovation
but they yes right yeah yeah yeah so so
yeah yeah no no we are so so let me
compare that those were I'm going to be
subjective here I find that that velvety
lien achillion he
Jennifer Lawrence is the genetic I call
you okay and this is very hard to do
right they must reflect make and
modulated in the solution space so that
is very hard to detect in other words
you have to you have to design the code
of life for every single problem okay
but this is what you have to do okay in
some sense the code we know the code of
life is the encoding for the genetic
algorithm which has done wonders for for
optimizing life event okay you know so
so for every single problem you want to
apply gentle goals you have to do you
have to be as clever okay in any way
not many practical successes know and
this is where I'm losing friends every
time I say that okay but but it's true
and in contrast simulated annealing
terrific so you know I love genetic
algorithms everybody loves genetic
Albert when you talk to them about the
Congress somebody who is interested in
solving a problem - practitioner their
eyes light up and they think that
they're going to go to the lab program
this thing and get amazing results in a
few couple of weeks and then couple
weeks they can either shut down okay
know that this is usually what happens
and in contrast simulate the neon
equally sticks are often the best known
algorithms for certain applications and
and practitioners who are better okay
and okay so I'll leave you I'll just I'm
just telling you what what is going to
be next I'm going to poke out talk a
little about the fascinating problems in
in evolution alright so thank you very
much and I'll see you in half an hour
that slide on genetic addresses
differently target is D here's Jordan
show them just say genetic algorithms
don't work so reading reading surveys so
I spend a lot of the past few days
trying to read for you to make a show
you know it very fair surveying of the
gentleman and you see a lot of
statements of the form that the genetic
algorithm bust with respect to many of
these things I mean I was only my
brother
excellent okay so so you know it's it's
amazing when people when when when when
white people in the audience to talk
about your next slide back to the
spaghetti things so they're right I mean
you're things saying okay well it
doesn't do any better I mean that's some
comment about the form of the right if
the input was given to you as strands of
spaghetti
this takes precisely one spin to find
the maximum right and similarly you know
if you were given integers in terms of
their prime factorization instead of as
bitstreams
they'd be easy to factor Enterprise
right and so when you're sort of talking
about protein folding that's sort of
thinking that your input is you know
some you know kind of you know beat
matrix of things but you know it's
nature actually acting on that input so
some examples also so I am I'm very
aware that the true story is amazing the
more complicated okay so you know so so
when when I mean oh I I want I know I
heard recently at Orkut to UCSF by
Posada protein researcher who basically
he's his point was that there are there
are there are a few you know that there
are there are proteins that were largely
as follows okay once once the flu first
amino acids come out the messengers go
out and say hey there is a protein that
starts this way starting okay and then
these are samples a whole faculty of
trainers you know chaperones who come
they're sort of anomaly you know in fact
there are membrane simulators among
so knowing otherwise the same young man
when you grow up you're going to go
through one of these okay so let's see
how good you are okay so you know and so
the story is sort of annoying credibly
you know sometimes when I when I go when
I go to talks in biology sort of you
know why I have the feelings haha so
listen okay so you know as as I hope I
made the mid-career so I know my mention
of the property of the four important
problems Oh totally
Tommy chicks or you know I you know I I
know I don't think that that it's it's a
computational problem